facing the end of the beginning let's do
it right now in Maycomb let's begin by
restoring this man to his family let's
begin with justice that's a scene from
Aaron Sorkin's Broadway adaptation of
the 1960 novel To Kill a Mockingbird the
plays not only nominated for 9 Tony
Awards tomorrow night it recently became
the highest-grossing play in Broadway
history another special stage version of
Harper Lee's novel just finished a
limited run jamie wax is here with more
on that Jamie good morning good morning
Anthony Harper Lee set to kill a
mockingbird in a slightly Fiction eyes
version of her hometown of Monroeville
Alabama it's a long way from Broadway
1,100 miles in fact it's a small and
remote town hours away from the nearest
airport but fans flock there each year
to experience her work in truly novel
ways to make it all the way to
Monroeville Alabama you have to really
want to be there the county seat of
Monroe County home to 6,500 is not
exactly on the map of the average
tourist but signs of its favorite
daughter Harper Lee are everywhere to be
able to come in and just experience the
rural community feel here it really
means a lot to people will ruzek is
executive director of development for
the region
one of the biggest engines of growth
here happens over a short five-week
stretch each spring as visitors flocked
to Monroeville for a one-of-a-kind
experience a live performance of To Kill
a Mockingbird the play based on Lee's
1960 novel is put on by people from the
community this is something we rely on
it's a tremendous tourist attraction
always has been for years but did you
ever see yourself as an actor never what
was your reaction when they asked you to
do this
well I laughed it off I ignore the
emails and the phone calls I just
assumed that this was a joke
having never been on stage you don't
just take on one of the most iconic
roles in American literature but that's
exactly
what's been happening here the past 29
years
ruzek just finished his first year in
the role of small-town lawyer Atticus
Finch how bitter things get these are
still our friends and this is still our
home ninth grader Megan Kirkland just
finished her third year as his daughter
scout now this is my last year because
I'm getting too old too tall but in a
few years I'm hoping to come back as
Miele so you're just just going to take
a little time off yes
describe the town for me on the day of a
production whoo three-ring circus yeah
Cathy McCoy came back two guests direct
the plays this season after serving his
director for the first 16 years and this
is where Harper Lee's father actually
practice law right and Harper Lee would
sit up in that balcony and watch her
daddy practice law before overseeing one
of America's most revered stories McCoy
worked as the courthouses museum
director we were raising money to
restore the Old Courthouse and one day I
set here and I thought why don't we just
maybe try to cast some folks from around
here create a community theater and we
can do it in this courtroom over nearly
three decades McCoy has taken the play
from Monroeville to stages across the
globe it's given the story town a chance
to write a new chapter
like many Monroeville was hit hard by
the exodus of manufacturing jobs in the
1990s
vanellope Hinds is on the Chamber of
Commerce it's been a huge impact
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
because of this play tourists come from
all over the world this season Alone's
from Australia Japan China
it seems everyone who's lived long
enough in Monroeville has a story about
Harper Lee who most knew as Miss Nell as
long as I knew was she always called me
kiddo
dot Bradley has been part of the cast
from day one the play has taken Bradley
way beyond Southwest Alabama
in Israel I was watching a jury and
several of the guys had water in their
eyes it was crying and when the play was
over she said I'm so sorry for what
happened and I told him sir you do not
have to apologize for what happened in
know we can't do anything about the past
but we can do something about now in the
future the role of Tom Robinson is
played by William Moseley
skid out had to face up to what I didn't
do sir nobody thought William the
policeman would be acting on a stage No
especially me Mosley is a law
enforcement officer in nearby brief
about 40 miles south of Monroe you play
a man wrongly convicted of a serious
crime what does it feel like to you to
to turn the tables and be on the other
side of that it's like I was almost
right there with Tom is that part of
what you went into your field for is to
try and create justice yes
and also to help people the very best
way I can the jury presiding over
Robinson's trial is selected from the
audience before each performance when I
first directed this play in 91
this grip did not call for a jury at all
and I'm like well I would like to take a
jury out of that audience and have them
feel what it's like to be on a jury that
convicts an innocent black man in the
name of God do your duty do you think
there's something in the experience of
seeing this production that touches
people even more deeply than it would if
everybody in it were professional actors
I do I think to understand that we're
all just everyday people really helps
add to the mystique of the play but to
always remember it was a sin to kill a
mockingbirds
while Jeff Daniels leads the cast of
Broadway's record-setting
the Monroeville performers make an
impact of their own way off-broadway
probably one of my favorite parts of the
show is afterwards and you get to hear
the experience of the audience we will
have people cry you know and inevitably
every single audience has an English
teacher and it typically she'll have two
or three of her students and they'll
refer to her as the crazy Mockingbird
lady and she'll just be standing there
crying because she's actually in the
courthouse and and has experienced this
emotional rollercoaster kill a
mockingbird has inspired us and appeal
to our better angels this book and this
play which is respect
if you respect one another then we can
go for that seems like a message that's
still very relevant today yes it is I
want to go see this yeah but you were
saying Jimmy that Harper Lee didn't
actually she wasn't a fan of this
production well if I give this she wrote
a lovely letter to the director Cathy
but she didn't like anything that's
shone a light on Monroeville it was her
place to hide out you know she didn't
like people talking about the book it
was the best way to shut her down they
all said in the town she had a lot of
Scout in her but there was some Boo
Radley there but no she was she was
lovely about the play in the later days
of it she just really didn't love people
coming to see her Amy thanks very much
what a great story